distinguished panel who who
represent
various aspects of this of this proposal
and can discuss it
there's of course
[Music]
there's of course
robert uh russindo from uh from uh who
is on the faculty at ubc
and um
and uh as patrick already pointed out
he's he's uh he's um he's
he's the person who proposed
uh measurement based quantum computing
on cluster states and
[Music]
as well as
its fault tolerant uh incarnation
um
we have um
we have uh daniel blatinski from uh was
that psycquantum and who
has worked extensively on on quantum era
correction in various forms color codes
uh maharani fermion in the topological
quantum era correction so and he can he
can comment i think about uh about the
relationship about this proposal to um
to the work that psy quantum is doing
and um we also have amir
safavi uh
naini who is uh who is a professor of uh
applied physics at uh at uh
caltech he he
and he works on uh
um
you know photonic uh phononic and
microwave devices for quantum sensing
and communicate and computation and so
again uh welcome everybody and
perhaps um
we we can start with uh with with a few
minutes uh you know your your
few minutes uh
give everybody a few few minutes
for your reaction to the talk as well as
any of these these topics so maybe we
can start with robert uh actually can i
throw in one minor correction
which is just that amir uh i'm lucky to
have him as my colleague at stanford
rather than at caltech oh sorry sorry uh
he does work on the caltech campus quite
frequently because he also has an
affiliation with amazon yeah i'm sorry i
i i meant to say stanford but i'm i
probably misspoke so sorry of you
thanks for the correction patrick
so um
would you like to say a few words robert
yeah oh thank you thank you uh
good so i think the the kind of the the
critical part
of the architecture the achilles heel if
if you like has already gotten
considerable attention
both
by what andrew said
and and umish what you asked about
namely this fact
that the length of the dla line scales
with a square of the size of the cluster
state so this is what's preventing you
from from a threshold result
and
[Music]
well i suppose
i think it's a good solution what was
already mentioned that why not have
various emitters working in concert with
one another i mean that might
um that might
kind of
ramp up technological difficulties i
mean now these emitters need to be
scheduled to work perfectly in sync
so so
photons from one emitter have to go into
the delay line of the other emitter and
so on and so forth and that has to to
work at the appropriate time so i can
imagine that this is more
difficult but maybe
for people like us we delegate those
difficulties to others
yeah so um
yeah so
[Music]
i i think that that is
if you want to go towards fall tolerant
quantum computation beyond keeping a
cubit alive for a very long time
i think that that would actually be
helpful
so good so so yeah for me that was the
central question but it has already
been pretty much addressed modulo maybe
some technical difficulties
so
maybe what
i
at a tiny technical thing that oh well
maybe not a technical thing that i would
like to get back to
is i was very surprised what you said
about
the the era
i mean the error model
i mean you said okay so now here we're
doing everything different from what you
would normally do do you have one qubit
interact with many
uh which could propagate errors badly
um but then you said okay
what we are only interested in and
that's of course correct
is error modulo cluster state stabilizer
we are
interested in equivalence classes of
errors and if
the equivalence class has a local error
then that's good
so if we have the time what
i'm surprised that this holds and if we
have the time
perhaps we could go back to the slide
when you showed this namely you showed
an x error happening directly after
hadamard
you know that that's that's the first
error you showed and what one could
compare this with
is
an x error happening one time step
later namely
after the conditional phase gate that
happened
so if you would propagate the former
error one step forward in time
compared to the second error it would
give you an additional sigma z
yeah so and and that will not further
propagate because
these do not propagate through
conditional face gates which i believe
so so it's really surprising to me i
want to emphasize this
that the technique actually works and
you can map everything effectively at
the end
to
um
to a local error model so i'm really
surprised by that finding and i wonder
whether that would persist
if you have
multiple emitters working in concert
good um
[Music]
and another
thing
i would like to
maybe hear more and there's other people
here on the panel who can
us more probing questions about it is
the interaction when a photon comes back
to
uh emitting
interacting with the emitter again so i
mean you want this to result
in a very specific interaction and also
a very strong interaction you know it
has to be conditional phase gate and how
you would model
i mean how realistic is this in in
physical devices okay so i think that
that is my
questions
for this panel discussions and hopefully
we can get back to them
in turn great
some of them
thanks thanks robert well possibly
if you move on to daniel uh
possibly
you know
for your comments as well as um
uh addressing
the the question that came up uh earlier
about how
how all this relates to the work at psy
quantum and possibly also robert's
question
maybe so you have a lot on your plate
[Music]
yeah so uh first of all thanks patrick
for the nice talk that was that was uh i
enjoyed it very much and i think what i
what i really like about this this kind
of architecture is that it really
highlights um both the advantages of
um photons and also the advantages of
what you can get from combining
different types of hardware approaches
so photonic with non-photonic components
um and you know on the photonic side i
i think uh your architecture really
nicely demonstrates how the use of these
long
um low loss photonic delays you know
specifically optical fiber how this can
really significantly reduce the number
of components that you need to build
to build this kind of large-scale
quantum computer and um well perhaps
sort of this already relates to
something that that andrast you know in
the in this interleaving
um approach that that we
that we talked about at cyquantum this
is sort of
one of the central
um
advantages that we would like to exploit
from from photons that you have this
this kind of
memory um capability in some sense with
with photons
um maybe one thing that i wanted to add
to what others said about this regime of
using multiple emitters
so um
i understand that you focused on you
know you focused on
how to build a
qubit and how to sort of store one qubit
um but in principle there's sort of no
conceptual difference to
building a cluster state for one qubit
or building a cluster state for an
entire computation because you know
they're both cluster states you're just
sort of
performing different types of
measurements
um
and there was sort of the
there was
in some sense this um
well the ppl highlighted that that you
know if you if you want to have a
constant number of components
um or if you're just using one single
emitter
uh you don't want to
you don't want this to sort of limit um
be a limiting factor when you
have to go to large code distances
but in the context of a full you know
entire quantum computation i would say
that there's also a secondary
consideration um to keep in mind
and essentially the kind of
consideration that i would like to
highlight is that
known useful quantum computations are
very large typically you know starting
at hundreds or even thousands of logical
cubits
uh and they also have extremely many
operations like 10 to the 10
non-clifford gates whether it's t gates
or toughly gates but if you really think
of this in terms of a cluster state you
know the kind of cluster state to have
in mind is is a is a huge
three-dimensional cluster state
something consisting of many many many
two-dimensional layers you know
trillions of layers
but with millions of qubits or let's say
a million cubits in each layer
and um
you know if you wanted to generate this
using a single quantum emitter
then
well first of all you would need a delay
that can contain a million cubits or a
million photons so how to build this is
one thing but even if you did
um you would have to ask yourself what
this implies for the speed of the
quantum computer
because
you need to reach a you know you need to
reach a certain number of logical qubits
to have a useful quantum computer but it
also needs to be fast enough to do
anything useful
um
and so these long delays they're really
great at getting lots of qubits out of
every component that you have but they
also slow down the quantum computation
so in some sense it's a it's sort of a
linear space-time trade-off
um yeah and you know if this quantum at
this one quantum emitter if it
if it can process one cubit every couple
of nanoseconds
uh and you need to process one million
cubits to generate a layer of this
cluster stage
then
it's basically it corresponds to it to
this kind of slow millisecond code cycle
and this could be a relatively long time
in terms of quantum computation
um you know so one thing i would be sort
of um
curious to hear about also um um hear
more about what the motivation was
behind behind having really constant
number of components
um and really what the notion of
constant means well we discussed this i
suppose
um
yeah so i could perhaps also comment
later on on
this uh
well someone else about fusion
how this relates to this fusion-based
quantum computation approach but
yeah
we could also postpone that to
later
um
so
um
let's see i i guess um
uh patrick do you want to i you you
responded to some extent already right
uh in in terms of saying you were
thinking not one emitter but multiple
limiters but maybe was there was there
more specific uh
sorry we can't hear you patrick
you mute
yeah so i could certainly respond
partially robert had a number of
questions and daniel also amir hasn't
had a chance to speak so maybe i'll just
respond quickly to daniel um
and
yeah i completely agree like the
about the
well
about the observation
that
by
forcing every interaction to go through
this one emitter you linear you know you
linear linearize the entire computation
and the preparation of the entire uh
quantum era correcting code
and you pay you pay a price um in terms
of the speed of the computation um
so the motivation
for us i think was mostly
kind of a
the idea was a demonstration
of an extreme case right like that we
really wanted to ask the question how
far could you go and you know if your
goal was just to make the fault tolerant
qubit um how simple could the
architecture be um with the
long longer term
vision being once you you know once you
know that extreme point uh and you know
um and i think well at psy quantum
you've probably been optimizing this
pretty hard but yeah for a lot of people
in the quantum computation community
they sort of think about the model where
you have a bunch of individually
controllable qubits um
and every one of them has to be kind of
controlled interacted
with
essentially at every time step step or
nearly so um
versus um this you know this opposite
extreme where you can you actually
just interact one at a time with the
data qubits and the data qubits have no
ability to interact
at all
um once you've done that then you can
try to interpolate right like given your
technological capability you can say
well um
with what we have available we're going
to optimize our ability to build a
useful comp quantum comp computer and
one that is actually
fast enough to be yeah uh to give us
answers on a time scale that that is
that is interesting uh by locating
ourselves here um
and
i think that opening up that realm of
possibility for perform that
optimization is basically was basically
the motivation
would you would you please thanks uh
yeah thanks uh i um actually my first my
first comment was very much related to
what you just said now that you know i
think this is uh like if you you can
sort of draw a map
where on the x-axis you have sort of a
control complexity and you know you can
control every single one of your qubits
and that has a control complexity of n
and then this has a control complexity
of one and then there's that space in
between that um
i think is really worth exploring um and
i also want to say that the i really
enjoyed your talk and i think it's also
um
uh very timely i think because um there
you know
um
there's i think on the hardware side
there's a starting to be a lot of more
interest in developing kind of memory
elements um there's efforts to serious
efforts to build quantum networks now
and and that's um
memories will be an important part of
that
so
um so hopefully we will see
a lot of advances on the hardware side
on developing
[Music]
memories that are compatible with
superconducting qubits
that can have
this coherence time that that gives you
this type of advantage
um and then i also
you know
one one comment is just from
experiments um
with um one type of um
memory element
uh which is the mechanical oscillator
which i'm more familiar with you know it
does seem like um the type of errors
that you get in those systems um they
you're much more likely to get the
phasing errors
um so the you know the kind of record
coherence times for a mechanical
resonators made out of silicon
are currently held by the caltech group
oscar painters group and you know they
they see
t1 times around a couple seconds but
their t2s are around you know one
millisecond
and that's sort of expected from the
sources of the coherence that you would
have in these devices it's typically
two level systems same story that you
have in superconducting qubits so you
have a lot of
defects in the structure that behave
like two level systems and you know if
if your device is small enough
the density of these defects is such
that your resonance just won't hit any
of them
um but um but they still fluctuate and
those fluctuations cause you know
fluctuations in the frequencies of these
oscillators so you can get um uh
reduction in the um t2 time because of
that but the t1 is not affected
um so
i mean one one question is can
um can the encoding
um
or i guess in this case yeah can can the
encoding be done in a way that that kind
of takes this bias into account at some
level and then
um
another
um
question i had i think maybe is related
to
um
[Music]
andrew's main point or one of his points
on on
what you call a component which is so in
this case you know you have um
you're calling the whole delay line uh
um a component and that component is
scaling and now you have more and more
modes in that component which is fine
because i'm okay with that because you
know
sure there's some challenges as you make
that larger and larger but in the end
there's just one point that you have to
really control um with wires going down
so it's you know it does scale
differently than a
superconducting system where as you
scale it like you have just way more
cables and way more processing
everything that has to be done
so but um
but my question was you know in the um
how does the error model
what is the error model in that
component because i can imagine for
example
depending on
the type of
delay line so let's let's say if you
have a superconducting delay line if i
if i have a
cosmic ray that comes down and hits some
part of it and then generates a bunch of
quasi particles you know that would that
would affect the temporal modes nearby
in some correlated way
um you might get it flips on you know
qubits
10 11
12 13 but nothing around there and so so
there's some i i wonder if your air
model takes that into account or
how much sort of effect you would expect
there
and that's i guess that's really related
to developing error models for those
components those are my questions thanks
thanks thanks amir that that was very
interesting actually may i may i jump in
with a naive question uh from the
viewpoint of a theorist so what um
you know um
can can you can somebody um uh address
this question of
um
how should i think of a delay line so is
should i just be thinking of well it was
clear i'm here from here from your
conception of it that it's you know my
naive view about well it's a fiber a
very long fiber with photons going
through well this is this is too naive
so how do we think of uh
what what a delay line is and
and what are the prospects of building
you know
uh
are they are there
um
natural bounds on
you can get delay lines this good and
you know going beyond that would be very
hard or well there's no end in sight etc
you know
as well as uh as well as well the other
question i had is something that you
asked but it would be good to touch on
it which is uh what what are what are
good error models for delay lines now
that there are
a large number of qubits going you know
being being
shuttled through them simultaneously so
so what how how would uh
everyone think about all these questions
uh yeah i guess for the delay lines um
so what what um
there's i mean the the
probably the best delay line in the
world is the optical fiber
so it's um
it's you know a piece of glass that's
kilometers long and um
in optical fiber you have losses that
are
0.15 db per kilometer so
um you know you make it
if you want to get to 20 you would
probably have to make it
i don't know like five kilometers long
or something
and then
the the disadvantage of the optical
fiber is that the
speed of light is
is very high and so
um
your temporal modes end up being fairly
large
so when you go to acoustic waves you
know you can you can make something that
looks a lot like um
it's imagine just a long string on a on
a chip
and
vibrations on that string you you
generate them on on one end of the chip
and they propagate to the other end and
they come back
and um
and the the speed of sound on a chip is
something like 5000
meters per second which is you know
fibers and attitudes slower than the
speed of light so
the length of these delay lines ends up
being much smaller the losses according
to the caltech results are um you know
something like 1 db per kilometer
instead of 0.15 db per kilometers so but
you know this is comparing something
that a graduate student made to
something with industries optimized for
40 years and nobel prizes have been
awarded for so it's sort of um you know
i think there's some room to improve
there
um
and uh
yeah and then the just the the way that
the excitation gets coupled to let's say
a super connecting qubit um you have to
um you know superconnecting qubit
depending on type of cubic transparent
cube there's an electric field that
oscillates
at um
let's say five gigahertz and you you
want that electric field to generate a
force
to generate the motion on the chip and
and you can for that you can use like a
piezoelectric material which converts
electrical fields into force and that's
something that that has also been
developed in the last few years
great
so i'll just throw in one little comment
i didn't show the slide but we also
worked at the
um
we analyzed the errors in the delay line
in the um
under the assumption not just of loss we
also did the the case where the errors
were dominated by defazing in the in the
delay line and what we found
was that we were within a factor of 10 i
think of the the kinds of um dephasing
rates that amir was seeing in in his
latest experiments and just to again to
reiterate um these types of systems
where you had
you know where you
where people are looking at these delay
lines and acoustic um
or
for acoustic phonons i think that has
been optimized um for maybe five or ten
years um just as you said by by a few by
a small number of people working in
universities and so um
you're looking at you know on the order
of five ten papers um as opposed to
thousands of people devoting their lives
to the case of optical fiber so um
you're seeing significant percentage
improvements you know year over year
[Music]
there was a significant backlog of
questions um
so maybe i'll i'll i'll start i'll go
back
maybe treat it as a stack um so amir had
asked about encoding for bias um
so the the codes that we're using right
now
um
treat
dephasing it don't
um
are not optimized for dephasing errors
they're as good for
for handling errors and one basis is
another but you certainly can design
codes um that um are better
at correcting for one error basis at the
expense of another one in the case where
errors are dominated by dephase and
that's worthwhile and i think actually
that
isaac working with an undergraduate
student has been looking at that and
there's some preliminary results that
look like something something like the
bacon short code um may actually work um
well uh in that regard and so i can't
say anything for sure but that's a
direction that there's definitely
unexpected unexplored space
um
and for correlated errors yeah so the
error model that we've been looking at
is just independent errors at every time
step and so we haven't looked at
correlated errors um
if
if you had a situation
where
a cosmic ray as you said a cosmic ray
resulted in a spray of quasi particles
and a significant fraction it corrupted
a significant fraction of the
cubits inside the
a delay line um
i'm
it doesn't seem like a huge stretch to
imagine that you you might actually um
get a logical error in that case right
you that you could get something that
looks like a a topologically non-trivial
uh
um
chain of errors um but we'd have to we'd
have to look at that
so robert had a
a number of questions and comments and
so i'll try to go through those um
so he was asking about the threshold
result
and
i would like to push back a little bit
um
on
the need for a threshold result um
just that i think this goes back to
andrew steen you know maybe 20 years ago
he wrote this paper in which he actually
asked not about thresholds but just
about using specific error correcting
codes and asking um what logical error
rates could be achieved with those with
those specific error correcting codes
without worrying about thresholds that
for any given computation um there's a
necessary error rate and as long as you
get below that error rate um
then
then you're fine um and so
we were looking you know we were
we were looking at error rates of 10 to
the minus
um again 10 to the minus 15 with cluster
states i forget exactly how big they
were but they were maybe on the order of
20 by 20. um
and so
that's a logical error rate where
um
you're unlikely to require
anything better than that i i think um
and so i wouldn't worry so much about
the threshold um the fact that this is
not a strict threshold result
um
so robert wanted to go back to the slide
asking about the x-bar after a
conditional phase gate so i can do that
um
quickly i think i actually even have
slides for that
so
um
this one here
many slides
okay so
he asked about i think
um
i want to make sure that i can see you
here
um
so you're asking about what would happen
if there were an x error after some of
the conditional uh z gates
and so this is actually an example of
that right here so imagine there's an x
error after these two yeah there's a
hadamard and then two conditional z
gates and then an x error so an
x error on the emitter
right here
and
because of the stabilizer structure
there's a stabilizer which is x on the
emitter and z on four z on seven
that propagates to
a z on four z on seven
and then the subsequent hadamard um and
controlled knot will swap the emitter
into position 10 at this point
oops okay i don't have a slide for the
swap but this emitter is going to get
swapped into position 10 and so 4 and 7
are going to be neighbors of ten
um
and that's that's what ends up happening
that the
um
there's going to be a collection of
physical errors in the cluster state
that are in the neighborhood of a single
qubit in the cluster state and in this
case the uh there'll be a
in a neighborhood of qubit number seven
uh number 10.
does that answer that question
uh
yes i mean i i guess i would have to to
yeah this is just an example i mean the
actual paper you know gives the proof in
all generality but um
this is the idea
good thank you
okay and
[Music]
go back to robert's list
there was one um
yeah maybe perhaps one one question we
were going to come back to which is how
what um
what what you what you propose relates
to what's i quantum oh yeah it's doing
i'd like to hear about that too actually
yeah then uh maybe let me comment about
sort of how this is similar and
different to
diffusion diffusion-based quantum
computing i mean i already pointed out
the similarity that where
you know fiber plays a prominent role
but fusion-based quantum computing is
sort of this
you know it's a
different model of computation that we
have in mind that's like quantum because
it's the model of computation that most
naturally
um in some sense most naturally
describes the components and operations
of the hardware that we have in mind
so um
this goes along the lines of what what
what patrick mentioned in the talk you
know everyone is familiar with the
circuit-based model of quantum computing
where you know where the objects are are
static qubits and entanglement is
generated through
um
through two-qubit gates
and you know there's something that
really naturally describes what more
reasonably naturally describes what you
would do on something like super
connecting qubits
and in the talk we've seen another model
of computation which is this measurement
based quantum computing with cluster
states
where um
really the entanglement is in the
objects these large entangled cluster
states
they're responsible for entanglement but
the operations they're just
disentangling uh single qubit
measurements
so fusion-based quantum computing is a
model that's somewhere in between where
sort of both the objects and operations
are responsible for for entanglement so
in intrusion-based quantum computation a
computation a quantum computation
corresponds to some arrangement of
a few
few qubit resource states so constant
size you know think of like something
like a 20 cubit
uh resource state
and
fusion instructions between uh pairs of
qubits from different resource states
fusion being a two qubit measurement so
uh why do we have this kind of um
you know why is it somehow important to
define a model like that because
uh the kind of components that that um
you know we have in mind for a photonic
quantum computer are essentially two
types of components one type is a and in
some sense they're sort of similar to
what
uh we've seen today one type of
component is a resource state generator
which is an emitter of not of single
qubits but of these few cubit resource
states you know something that on a
clock cycle say every nanosecond
produces
uh a few photon entangled state
uh you know not a very small number but
you know a constant size number like
something like 20 photons entangled in
some specific way are produced by a
resource state generator
that being one type of component and the
other type of component being
well in the talk we had a detector which
is sort of a single qubit measurement
device
but
in fusion-based quantum computing it's a
two-qubit measurement device that
essentially performs
well performs type two fusions which are
essentially two-qubit bell basis
measurements
okay so sort of
both of these components are responsible
for entanglement in some sense
um now there's no you know it's
vision-based quantum computing is no
more powerful than than sort of
cluster-state-based quantum computing or
circuit-based quantum computing you can
translate from one to the other it's
just about what sort of naturally
describes the kind of
um
you know the kind of components that you
want to use to to execute your quantum
computation
um
yeah and
so
yeah i guess we're in this in this
interleaving
um in this paper about interleaving
there's a
an architecture is described that's
um sort of
you know tries to exploit fiber delays
or
low loss uh optical delays in the same
kind of way where you um where you can
use
optical fiber as some sort of temporary
memory to drastically reduce the number
of resource state generators that you
need to build such a large scale quantum
computer so essentially you know you can
think of a large quantum computer in
this fusion based quantum computing um
setting as a network
of many of these resource state
generators you know they're sort of
similar to these emitters but they
produce something more complicated than
just single qubits
um
yeah and
by using optical fiber as a temporary
memory you can reduce the number of
you know you can reduce the number of of
these resource state generators that you
need to build something that's
equivalent to a million qubit device
so for instance you know instead of
um
maybe to also comment sort of what what
what does a
optical fiber delay line look like well
you know one kilometer of optical fiber
um yeah speed of light and fiber is
is you know two-thirds of the speed of
light in vacuum but
it's um you know if you send in photons
fast enough if you send in photons every
nanosecond into an optical fiber then
you can really think of a one kilometer
long optical fiber delay line
as sort of this this piece of
uh
optical fiber is something that stores
5000 photons at any given time you know
there are 5000 photons in this in this
piece of optical fiber one photon
entering every nanosecond
um and essentially you know if you sort
of design your architecture the right
way
uh similarly to what we've seen today
then you can use this to
get this
factor of 5000 reduction in the number
of components that you need to build
um
yeah maybe a sort of an additional
comment
i think if you wanted to make andrew
happy and really provide sort of a a
threshold result
you could you could still do this in the
sort of multi-emitter regime
uh if you were you know if you just
uncoupled the
code distance from the length of the
fiber uh from sorry from the from the
length of the delay line that you want
to use
because essentially you know the task is
to produce some large cluster stage
um
and to use a maximum delay length that
still allows you to do that below some
sort of error rate
and you know if how you partition this
large cluster state into smaller chunks
doesn't need to depend
on
the code distance because these are sort
of two completely separate numbers
so there is still a threshold result in
there it's just not sort of the way it's
uh
um
i suppose it's not something that you
can present with just a single component
then
great um
[Music]
patrick do you have any anything further
to say about that yeah well that's
i
i definitely agree we as i said we
haven't thought carefully about how to
stitch together
these little pieces of clusters or
cluster state uh into a larger cluster
state but it clearly is possible and the
question is just how you would do it in
the most intelligent way um and once it
once you do that it does start to seem
quite similar to
your architecture at psy quantum
but perhaps not optimized for
um
the kinds of measurements that you can
perform on the photons like the two it
sounds like the two photon measurements
in the bell basis is a useful
uh a useful primitive for actually
creating entanglement that we're not
trying to exploit here
but that if you thought of this in terms
of multiple emitters each emitter
capable of making a chunk each emitter
would be very much like one of your um
your resource state generators and then
there's this extra fusion process which
is supposed to
stitch them together into some larger
resource state which we actually haven't
even uh
pursued from an experimental standpoint
i expect that there would be some
there was a question about
the quality of the controlled zed gate
when when a photon or phonon comes back
to the emitter
and
if the phonon or
or photon is coming back to the same
emitter that generated it then i would
expect the interaction
[Music]
to be better than it would be coming you
know to a different you know to a
different emitter just because uh
the
the profile of the pulse is going to be
exactly matching the you know the
uh because it was generated by the same
emitter uh that it is now interacting
with it's gonna it's gonna be optimized
um and so there could be
additional diff additional difficulties
that aren't present at the abstract
level when you try to stitch things
together but might be present at the
kind of physical level in terms of
engineering the quality of the gates
[Music]
and we'd have to check as robert said
you know whether the error model in in
this picture would remain local
if you actually started trying to stitch
together
multiple emitters i suspect that it
would
but we'd actually
would always ask to check
if i could just inject for three seconds
exactly local would not be necessary
because you're dealing with a
topological code i mean you you can
live with three local errors for example
live with what sorry what kind of
yeah yeah we do with qualities they
wouldn't really bite you
oh yeah right like our our errors do
appear in little
uh in little clusters or clusters a bad
word but in neighborhoods of a single of
a single qubit rather than being just
isolated individual errors
great so um if there are if there are
any final comments um because we are we
are pretty close to the end of uh
time for the panel so
given more time i would have liked to
discuss these catastrophic events and
the fact that you have a five
kilometer delay line actually maybe that
helps you if so so you can i mean
normally that would be coiled up
i suppose this photonic line but i mean
you could actually lay it out in space
at least around your lab and maybe that
helps actually with these catastrophic
errors
but i don't want to start another
discussion
at this moment
to be continued
um
anything anything else to add
[Music]
okay
if not then
thank you amir daniel and robert for a
very interesting panel and
and thanks a lot patrick it was a
beautiful talk again and
really enjoyed it
well thank you for organizing this i
actually i really enjoy this format it
was it was a lot of fun
great
so see you all next week um
next week we have uh
uh misha lukin who
will speak about exploring new
scientific frontiers with programmable
quantum simulators i guess that's his
200 cubit uh
[Music]
two-dimensional arrays i guess but um so
see you all next time and thank you very
much
thank you bye
thank you bye bye thank you